je vais vous raconter tout de même deux
petites anecdotes donc la première s'est
passé le 14 janvier 2011
je pense que chacun d'entre nous dans
cette salle se souvient pas ce qu'il a
fait ce jour là
donc moi comme beaucoup de tunisiens
j'étais à l'avenue bon avec un ensemble
d'amis et puis par malchance il y avait
deux journalistes allemands juste à côté
de nous et je ne tiens vous ne savez pas
comment s'adresser à eux ou en allemand
en anglais qui étaient à mes amis m'ont
poussé ils m'ont dit tiens je vais
parler aux journalistes
donc moi j'arrive comme ça je rassemble
tout mon courage je vous rappelle
c'était devant ministère de l'intérieur
ben ali était encore là donc j'arrive je
commence à discuter avec le journaliste
donc tout allait bien
jusque là tout allait bien et puis il ya
deux ou dc en syrie comme on les
reconnaît bien os moustaches et puis en
général un blouson qui fait trois fois
plus de taille que normalement ils
viennent et commence à me filmer comme
ça là je me dis ça y est je vois tout le
film poule scénario y aurait pu se
passer
donc je commence à réfléchir je
m'approche arrière du pantalon et courir
le plus rapidement possible donc je
commence vraiment envisagé ce scénario
et je rentre à la maison il était 17h
vraiment complètement stressée bon
j'étais content quand même de la journée
passée et puis vers 18h30
il ya benali qui décolle et là vraiment
j'ai beaucoup de chance il est tellement
de chance en fait que le jour où je me
suis dit mon destin aurait pu basculer
eh ben le dictateur est parti donc ce
soir là c'était vraiment la fête non
seulement parce que c'était la
révolution les départs de ben ali
mais en plus de ça j'allais m'en sortir
et donc à partir de ce jour là j'ai
commencé vraiment à me dire allez
maintenant que ben ali est parti qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour le pays et donc
avec quelques amis en a lancé ce jour là
une association qui s'appelle le pacte
tunisien que je vous invite à aller voir
il ya à peu près 8000 personnes
maintenant qui travaille pour le pacte
tunisien mais c'était pas l'événement le
plus
pourtant cette semaine puisque une
semaine plus tard je reçois un coup de
fil d'un numéro assez bizarre un numéro
avec plein de 0.21 c'était quelqu'un du
pôle humanitaire
oui bonjour monsieur revel en vous
demande au premier ministère on veut que
vous veniez nous aider parce que voilà
en fait c'est la révolution
et puis on sait que vous avez fait
quelques travaux sur la tunisie par
ailleurs donc franchement ce jour là
c'était un coup de fil je sentais un le
poids du téléphone là mon oreille et
puis j'ai gg j'ai très peu dormi ce soir
là j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et comme tout
tunisien indépendant qui se dit voilà je
suis indépendant je prends mes décisions
toute seule je suis allé consulter ma
mère donc oui à vous reconnaissez on
utilisa que je suis donc je vais voir ma
mère judy écoute maman on m'a appelé
bonjour maman d'ailleurs ainsi tu me
regardes on m'a appelé au premier
ministère et on m'a demandé de rejoindre
le gouvernement
là ma mère ça va pas ça va pas la tête
mon fils qui travaille chez mckinsey
dans bureau il est ou sur les champs
elysées tu voyages en classe affaires
mais tu tues tu veux que tu veut
en l'air ta vie en fait un vin je
regarde comme ça je dis mais non maman
s'était pas exactement ça l'objectif
donc je continue à réfléchir et puis le
lendemain je vais d'abord j'ai dit
comment franchement si je ne prends pas
cette décision
aujourd'hui si je ne me lance pas où et
d un tant soit peu et modestement ce
pays
je ne serai plus jamais moi même et donc
pour la première fois j'ai décision
contre l'avis de mes parents c'était
d'ailleurs être la première décision que
j'ai pris et donc j'ai vraiment pu
regarder l'art et cette révolution de
l'autre côté de la barrière
donc à l'intérieur ça que j'ai mis à
cette photo de volcans parce que j'ai
regardé de l'intérieur ce qui se passait
dans le pays
et c'était une expérience magnifique
alors une année se passe bien entendu
j'ai fait énormément de choses j'ai
travaillé au ministère soit il y avait
et on va dire des manifestations tous
les jours
sit in des demandes farfelues des
demandes très légitime aussi j'ai fait
le tour du pays
et puis le fameux 23 octobre 2011 était
arrivé cette journée magnifique dont on
se souvient tous on est tous allés voter
c'était vraiment féerique c'était
magnifique
on se disait c'est génial on va devenir
singapour on va devenir la suisse
et puis voilà ce qui s'est passé après
on est arrivé voilà donc la tunisie a eu
tous les maux de la terre on dirait que
la baguette magique était devenue une
baguette maudite
c'est à dire tout ce qu'on se disait
disait en fait que tout allait se
transformer et finalement on découvre en
fait que non et à l'impression en fait
que ça va de mal en pire et puis j'ai
commencé à réfléchir et je me suis dit
mais est ce que c'est vraiment la
révolution qui a fait ça finalement je
pense que c'est 3000 ans de dictature
qui ont produit ça c'est pas une
baguette maudite autant qu'il n'y a pas
de baguette magique qui va régler tous
nos problèmes
ce sont 3000 années de dictature qui en
produit ce qui est arrivé mais on a
commencé à nous rendre compte du du mal
dans lequel on vivait donc c'est clair
un matin vous penser qu allissa
lorsqu'elle a fondé carthage elle était
démocratique
pas du tout ouais ou alors a ras-le-bol
al fath et miou nous est la leur à
bessilles où nous tous et tous ces gens
qui se sont succédé à la tête de la
tunisie bien sûr que vous avez eue en
cours d'histoire dans des séances de
dicter collective on était tous en train
d'écrire bêtement à apprendre par coeur
et a oublié le lendemain
si bien que ce système éducatif
auxquelles la majorité d'entre nous ont
fait partie ou en tout cas l'école
publique nous a ôté notre immunité
mental notre immunité intellectuelle
cette immunité intellectuelle qui comme
celle du corps lorsque le corps est
attaqué par un virus il a une humilité
qui réagit qui le défend malheureusement
nous notre école elle nous a mal
enseigné l'histoire la géographie et
albin wataneya le talent belle est ce la
meilleure la tâche qui les aiment les
takfiris les mines etc etc
on nous a mal an c'est enseigner ces
matières là et du coup on est les
premiers exportateurs de terroristes on
est vraiment une machine à produire des
gens qui peuvent devenir des terroristes
parce que nous n'avons plus cette
immunité mental et du coup n'importe
quel virus peut venir s'installer et peu
détériorée l'avenir de notre jeunesse
mais finalement avec un peu de recul je
me suis dit que c'était pas cette
tunisie pour laquelle j'étais revenu
c'était une autre tunisie c'était une
tunisie avec du génie utiliser une
tunisie qui a été la premier le premier
pays arabe musulman africain à abolir
l'esclavagé une tunisie qui a produit la
première constitution du monde arabe une
tunisie qui a ramené des philosophes des
lumières du monde arabe nous avions pas
à des drames dalila michel salmon sauf b
on a vu finalement une génération de
gens qui en réfléchi et qui ont
transformé la pensée tunisienne la
pensée arabe ou musulmane donc cesser
cette tunisie qui a pour laquelle
j'étais revenu et c'est cette tunisie
que je voulais encore revoir et c'est
pour cela que j'attends énormément de
cette révolution
j'attends énormément de cette révolution
j'attends une révolution qui est sur
tous les domaines
j'attends qu'on sorte de nos barrières
j'attends on m'a mis un cercle rouge ici
j'ai franchement jeu j'en sors moi
j'attends beaucoup plus de cette
révolution j'attends une révolution
politique
une révolution économique une révolution
sociale une révolution culturelle sur la
partie politique
on nous a présenté une démocratie
représentative
finalement c'est ce sont les modèles qui
existent un peu partout et on peut
retomber très rapidement dans une
oligarchie
c'est à dire que le pouvoir politique
est très proche du pouvoir économique
il prend l'argent de le pouvoir
économique est très proche du pouvoir
médiatique également et on se retrouve
avec une démocratie où c'est une pseudo
dictature temporaire où on donne le
pouvoir une minorité sans pouvoir le
reprendre
aujourd'hui j'attends de la tunisie
d'aller au delà de ses frontières est
d'arriver à faire la démocratie directe
la démocratie où chacun d'entre nous
peut réellement participer au quotidien
à faire des choix et c'est possible
il y a 20 ans en avait ni téléphone
portable ni internet
on ne pouvait pas imaginer tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire aujourd'hui d'ici 15 ans
peut-être en 2030 on pourrait dépasser
toutes ses frontières et faire en sorte
que la tunisie sera le premier modèle de
démocratie directe dans le monde
économiquement
maintenant il est prouvé
scientifiquement
aujourd'hui que les modèles de
libéralisme incontrôlé
ce sont des modèles qui accentue les
inégalités entre les gens 1 % de la
population mondiale détient 50 % des
richesses
je pense qu'on peut reporter sa à la
tunisie également les richesses sont
très mal répartie il y à 360 secteurs
qui sont fermés à la concurrence et je
peux vous assurer qu'il ya des barons
qui tiennent ces secteurs-là et qui se
remplissent les poches tranquillement
j'ai été de l'autre côté de la barrière
du côté des gens qui font les lois et je
peux vous assurer que ça existe et il
faut que ça change
nous devons créer un modèle d'économie
qui créent de la richesse d'un côté mais
qui arrive à la répartir d'une manière
inclusive c'est à dire que la croissance
elle doit profiter et à tout le monde en
même temps on doit créer de la richesse
certes mais on doit la répartir
correctement
socialement socialement aujourd'hui nous
vivent dans nous avons deux paysans ne
nous avons les tunisiens qui ont des
voitures qui ont la cnss qui en la
sécurité sociale qui ont un régime de
retraite qui vont voter
je pense que la majorité d'entre nous
dans cette salle sans dans cette
situation là mais nous avons également
un million de tunisiens qui travaillent
et qui n'ont pas de couverture sociale
vous vous rendez compte il y a trois
millions et demi de tunisiens qui
travaillent il ya un mais deux millions
et demi seulement inscrit à la cnss les
autres en fait il n'existe pas et vous
savez quoi
les autres vous les voyez tous les jours
les autres c'est ce qui l'a vos voitures
c'est ce souffle aux tic ce match arrive
plus à 5h30 du matin c'est vos femmes de
ménage avez-vous pensé à ces femmes de
ménage ya cent mille femmes de ménage en
tunisie je suis certain que vous les
voyez vous les côtoyer tous les jours
des autres et nous ne pouvons pas être
un pays digne de ce nom
si on n'arrive pas à fusionner des de
tunisie il faut qu'on arrive à fusionner
cette tunisie et faire en sorte que
c'est comme l'allemagne de l'est et les
plaines de l'ouest
eux ils avaient au moins une barrière
physique nous ce sera d'autant plus
facile parce qu'on n'a pas de mur
l'autre tunisie il est en face de nous
il faut vraiment qu'on fusionne et donc
c'est très important de ce point là et
enfin et ça c'est ma partie préférée
il faut qu'on arrive à changer notre
système de valeurs
je me suis amusé avant de venir vous
voir il ya deux jours à collecter à
l'ensemble d'expression qu'on utilise
tous les jours entre new matin on
utilise matin tous les jours donc pas et
c'est vraiment des expressions
antivaleurs attelle et dans les pays qui
réussissent c'est pas ces expressions là
qui se dit donc par exemple salle l'acca
alouf aura des rallyes 5 go au jeu j'en
passe parce que on m'a dit l'autre jour
qu'il y avait beaucoup d expression
nouvelle sas et des expressions qu'on
utilise match quelqu'un qui a sa la
cassure son cv c'est le roi du monde
dont tunisie c'est l'anti honnêteté
directement ensuite le civil et le style
physique ou chimie art à la 6e
il faut qu'on arrive à revivre dans
notre bataille faut qu'on arrête de
vivre comme si on vivait dans le pays
des autres grata dans le pays d autres
ont fait pas comme ça en jette pas des
trucs dans la rue on s'en fout pas en
fait de ce qui se passe autour de nous
donc c'est très important de remettre en
cause ces éléments là ensuite le courage
et les raffineries veille à aucune maman
même la mienne qui n'a jamais dit à ses
enfants et les raffineries mais arrêtant
il faut qu'on ait du courage il faut
commencer il ya nos enfants le courage
et donc ses expressions là il faut qu'on
les remette en cause ensuite à l'ail
alors celui on pointe du doigt en disant
pareil sans cv avec les filles est finie
le pauvre et même s'ils portent pas de
lunettes
on va lui mettre des lunettes et s'il a
pas de bouton en valais dessinée et ça y
est c'est fini un catastrophe et de
files
mais alors fels il fut un temps où il
fallait société une valeur c'est
quelqu'un en fait qui essaye de
réfléchir c'est quelqu'un qui essaye de
trouver quelque chose de nouveau
motion teana bien sûr aux shoots et
racolage raconte à genève gauche moderne
enfin la bouche enfin les aides le
meilleur pour la fin la persévérance
donc pour nous quelqu'un qui échoue
c'est catastrophique an men et j'aime ce
repos ou chafaï des week-ends hilton out
ou mai et les rires donc un entrepreneur
qui échoue vous savez aux états unis
quelqu'un qui échoue il le met sur son
cv et cesser les premières personnes à
être recruté parce que ce sont des gens
qui ont eu l'expérience et après tous
échoué c'est aussi avoir de l'expérience
et du coup on peut mieux réussir par la
suite on peut transmettre mieux la
partie de gauche c'est vraiment la
meilleure
la procrastination donc avec gil
goldstein échoue donc al jarreau doit
inch'allah
yamna h tao tchoffo combien d'entre vous
dit ça tous les jours où l'entend au
mois tous les jours ma femme aille aille
a personne qui peut avancer dans sa vie
si ils continuent à utiliser en tout cas
bêtement ses expressions je ne dis pas
qu'il faut plus les utiliser du tout
risque de me faire taxer de je ne sais
quoi mais il faut arriver à se remettre
en cause et à remettre en cause ces
éléments de notre culture du le
fatalisme mais comment on peut enseigner
à nos enfants ces valeurs de fatalisme
allard al awad al abaaj nouveau en
europe ou en france
à un moment il avait 4000 morts sur la
route ils ont décidé qu'ils allaient
baisser ce chiffre aujourd'hui ils en
sont à mille cinq cents c'est le 1500
qu'on a aujourd'hui deux morts sur la
route en tunisie mais pour nous à l'oral
à nadal on se dit jamais pourquoi on met
pas la ceinture on se dit pas en fait
que l'on respecte pas des signalisations
on se dit pas que nos routes flamandes
et true north american dad c'est ça la
tunisie qu'on veut prêt à proposer à nos
enfants
et ben moi je dis que non je dis que le
génie tunisien à devoir revenir et on
doit réellement mettre l'ambition aussi
au politiquement économiquement
socialement et culturellement
je la vois très très haut cette ambition
je la vois aussi haut que les montagnes
de l'himalaya et et franchement moi j'ai
envie de monter parce que vous savez
quoi
homélie a dit qu' on vivait et qui s'est
placé poubelle
franchement moi pour passer mes chers il
ya un siècle presque disait roma la
lazio gmail yahoo abd al banna profanes
des souvenirs forts le thomas est là je
ne veux pas donc mon temps tous ensemble
merci beaucoup